الوضع على الخطوط الاماميه في باخمه صعب
ويزداد تعقيدا
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم معركه السيطره على مدينه
ضخمه الاستراتيجيه تحتدم حيث قالت ميليشي
لانها تخوض حرب شوارع مع القوات
الاوكرانيه في هذا المدينه بينما قرر
رئيسها الاوكراني بصعوبه الوضع الميداني
وكشف ان قوته بدات التدريب على استخدام
دبابات تشالنجر البريطانيه في بريطانيا
واشنطن تسقط من تضن صينيا تشتبه في قيامه
بانشطه التجسس
واستخدمت في ذلك طائره مقاتله من طرازيه
في 22 واكدت انه جزء من اسطول صيني يراقب
خمس قارات بينما نذرت بيجيل باستخدام
القوه المبالغ فيها لاسقاطه وقالت انها
تحتفظ بحق استخدام الوسائل اللازمه
للتعامل مع المواقف المماثله
قراران للاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع
بفرض حظر على استيراد مشتقات النفطروسيه
ووضع سقف لاسعاره يدخلان حيز التنفيذ
وترمي هذه الاجراءات الى تقليص عائلات
روسيا من مبيعات الطاقه وبالتالي قدرتها
على تمويل حربها على اوكرانيا موسكو نذرت
بالخطوه وقالت انها ستعمق انعدام التوازن
في اسواق الطاقه العالميه
الثلوج والبرد القارص يلقيان بظلال ثقيله
على حياه النازحين واللاجئين السوريين حيث
حاصرت الامطار الغزيره والعواصف الثلجيه
المخيمات في الشمال السوري ولبنان ما ادى
لتضرر مخيمات عده في هاتين
بينما حذرت مؤسسات اغاثيه من تداعيات
تراجع المعونات الدوليه الى اللقاء